[Musique]
c'est le candidat surprise de cette
élection présidentielle de 2022 j'ai
décidé de me présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
édité entre 13 et 17% d'intentions de
vote selon les sondages a commencé
autour de 6% et depuis ça a été une
poussée extrêmement fort dit eric
zemmour s'est imposé depuis septembre
comme le chef d'orchestre controversé de
cette campagne présidentielle bfm tv
n'est pas est morte et les routes parler
de ma candidature pour la première fois
sur le plateau de face à baba ce soir il
va être confronté à dix personnalités
durant près de deux heures le candidat
du parti reconquête va répondre à
différentes thématiques et sujets qui
sont les fondements de son programme
comme l'insécurité ou l'immigration et
d'autres sujets sur lesquels l'homme
politique ne s'est pas encore vraiment
exprimer mais très attendus comme
l'économie ou encore la santé mais à
quelques heures du direct comment va se
dérouler cette nouvelle émission qui
seul le début de la course à l'elysée
préparatifs secret coulisses nous allons
tout vous révéler ce soir eric zemmour
fait face à bah
merci sur place yoplait merci à vous
merci garenne chants rauques en est avec
nous vous êtes le porte parole de la
reconquête le parti d'eric zemmour et
merci à gauthier le bris journalistes
pour ses news vous suivez eric zemmour
depuis des semaines et des semaines
depuis le 18 septembre exactement depuis
le 18 septembre alors est ce que c'est
un rendez vous important pour lui dans
un instant en direct sur ces 8 parce que
vous en avez entendu par x n'a
évidemment réduite on en a même parlé
avec lui en arménie puisque vous savez
il remanie à quelques jours évidemment
que c'est très important puisqu'il va
parler à un public qui le connaît moins
bien un public beaucoup plus jeunes pas
forcément acquis à eric zemmour donc
effectivement c'est une émission
important que ce soit pour lui alors
gare est né ce qu'il a préparé des
missions comme les autres ou bien il a
travaillé c'est pas parce que c'est pas
une émission de tf1 de france 2 qui est
bas moins la travailler bien sûr ça a
toujours été quelqu'un qui bosse
énormément
ils travaillent les sujets qu'ils
pensent qu'ils vont sortir il se prépare
il imagine les invités qui va peut-être
avoir il a moins l'impression que sur le
logis et respecte toutes les émissions
de télé de la même façon parce que c'est
les français qui respecte d'air ce qui
sait que c'est les français qui vont
regarder donc il prépare toujours les
émissions la même façon que ce soit une
grande émission de tf1 une grande
émission de ses huit ou une petite
émission sur un autre média alors
est-ce que habituellement gt qui
travaille beaucoup ses interventions
tout ça on peut poser toutes les
questions également est-ce qu'il est au
courant de tout dans l'émission moi je
pourrai pour répondre également je sais
pas alors je vous le dis il n'est pas au
courant et mien les face à face qui
l'aura il alors si si il sait à peu près
les face à face qui draguent les a pas
tous et je tiens bien sûrs et c'est vrai
que vous pouvez pour élire je n'ai ni eu
eric zemmour au téléphone ni vu eric
zemmour avant cette émission c'est ni vu
ni eu au téléphone j'ai eu sarah knafo
ca ca conseillère voilà sur des quelques
dossiers on s'est vus deux fois ou deux
trois fois mais c'est vrai que je n'ai
pas vu ni eu au téléphone et je pense
c'était un désir de l'un et l'autre
voilà de ne pas se voir avant de ne pas
se parler avant sinon ça aurait cassé un
truc oui je la trouvais thème interdit
au quinté aucun repère une instru aucun
thème interdit bancaire vellamo
maintenant donc
si vous avez des infos sur sur cette
émission ce que c'est important pour
eric zemmour et chez les autres
candidats est ce qu'ils vont la suivre
cette émission lui ont tous le regarder
parce que d'abord ils ont ils ont une
trouille c'est de devoir la faire parce
qu'ils maîtrisent donc ils ont très peur
ce qu'ils maîtriseront rien du tout et
l'elysée en particulier regarde beaucoup
parce que ça c'est quelque chose qu'ils
ont particulièrement travaillé
l'électorat des jeunes etc donc si
zemmour commence à monter là dedans
c'est un peu embêtant pour eux et puis
vous avez un électorat entre guillemets
des gens qui vous regardent qui sont
plus populaires que que ce qu'ils ont
l'habitude aussi de toucher donc voilà
c'est pour eux c'est un enjeu important
ils vont regarder ce que vous allez
produire comme émission politique face à
un candidat à la présidentielle ça ça
les intéresse beaucoup heureux et
surtout et surtout il exhume on est très
content de pouvoir parler à des gens qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de l'écouter il
valait ya beaucoup de gens je pense dans
votre lit dans votre auditoire qui
connaît eric zemmour de nom mais qui n'a
aucune idée des ide équipe qu'ils
pensent qu'elles sont ses idées qu'elles
sont ok il se croit il prend pas une
ride et remet en venant ce soir en
direct qu'en faisant le jt de tf1 où ces
mêmes règles et mots on n'a pas peur de
grand chose ou de grand monde donc donc
là il est un pur ce que ça peut être
qu'au bon pour lui mais c'est au bar on
n'est pas magicien mais je pense que il
est surtout très content de pouvoir
parler à des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de l'entendre est-ce que ça
m'excite davantage parce qu'il ya plein
de jeunes ya le public est extrêmement
variée pas dans sa tête mais moi j'ai en
tout cas je suis très heureux qu'il le
fasse quand je sais pas si vous êtes
excité on veut pas le savoir
très plaisir c'est vrai gauthier c'est
vrai que c'est une émission qui a tendu
parce que c'est vrai que moi je vous dis
la vérité j'ai jamais on m'a jamais
autant parlé d'une image que j'allais
faire c'est incroyable et puis vous
savez eric zemmour est sans cesse qu'il
a une partie de l'électorat et l'air
plus bourgeois et une partie de
l'électorat du rassemblement national
plus populaires donc ça peut être aussi
lui permettre de parler à cette deuxième
jambe la plus populaire parce que bon on
reconnaît qu'il ya une partie du vote
bourgeois mais peut-être n'a pas encore
totalement une partie du vote populaire
pour l'instant pour résumer c'est le
candidat des riches s'ils arrivent à
réussir votre mission est un peu devenu
un candidat populaire mais c'est pas
gagné pour l'instant alors les questions
pouvez poser toutes les questions vous
évoquez aussi oui gilles briand call if
j'ai une question pour vous c'est réglé
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes est ce
que vous êtes dans un état d esprit
belliqueux est ce que vous avez envie
qu'eric zemmour vous dise des choses
particulières comment leur allaient
l'interroger nous dire moi je veux
traiter tous les candidats de la même
façon donc tous ceux qui disent non ici
sont traités de la même façon on a
choisi cinq personnes qui sont contre
lui cinq personnes qui sont plutôt avec
lui pour vraiment voilà qu'on soit dans
une équité totale moi je vais avoir un
entretien avec lui avec les autres
personnes qui seront là voilà au début
d'émission mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai
besoin de comprendre des choses mais je
ne suis pas là pour insulter ou
invective et voilà après bien sûr il y
aura dix matches puisque ce sera 10
matchs ce soir il sera il aura dix
matches à faire ce soir eric zemmour
face à différentes personnes face à moi
j'ai plutôt envie de savoir le pourquoi
du comment il a envie d'être président
pourquoi il fait toutes ces déclarations
j'ai envie d'en savoir un petit peu plus
sur lui et que les français en sache un
peu plus sur lui et qu'ils comprennent
voilà moi j'ai plein de questions que j
aurais je la lui poser les questions
peut-être que les français ont vite dû
poser puisque maintenant il brigue la
présidence de la république donc c'est
vrai qu'on a envie de savoir ce qu'il a
à ce qu'il a dans la tête oui valérie
est ce que la veille du match justement
à trouver des interlocuteurs pour ce
faire s'affronter à eric les mots n'ont
alors que justement on dit oui tout ça
tout ça c'est vrai que là on a dû
refuser des gens je vous dis comme à
l'entrée d'une boîte ont été refusées
des gens c'est vrai qu'il ya énormément
de gens qui voulaient venir face à eric
zemmour après c'est vrai que voilà
vous dit j'ai rajouté une personne que
j'avais envie de voir face à eric
zemmour hier c'est seiller hier je
rajoute et karim zéribi voilà qui ont
envie de voir face à face à eric zemmour
un moment donc voila sinon c'est vrai
que sk meier n'a refusé non est ce que
lui en a refusé non non non franchement
non il n'a pas il nous a il nous a
refusé personne a prononcé après moi
j'essaie plutôt mes équipes qui ont vu
avec ses équipes vous direz que c'est
mort et moi on sait pas eu du tout au
téléphone ni vu là dessus c'est vrai
vous pouvez le lire mais on ne sait
jamais rencontré de notre vie c'est une
grande première c'est vrai alors on a 11
ans mais je vous dis on a on a des gros
on a une aura et meriem aymeric caron
qui sera là je voulais qu eric naulleau
soit là aussi sombre est-ce qu'on peut
être complètement opposé à toutes les
idées d'un ami parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai envie de moi face à face avec au
milieu je leur posais des questions je
voulais qu'ils et alexis corbière bien
sûr il y aurait aimé que bell revel qui
sera là qui lui je vous le dis n'a rien
compris à son programme économique qui
veut qu'il y ait un détail un peu son
programme économique parce qu'il n'a pas
compris il ya mathias wargon qui sera là
il ya christine kelly il sera là
également parce que c'est vrai qu'eric
zemmour a changé la victime qui dit
allons en bien ou en mal mais il a
changé sa vie il ya charles d'ornellas
ce qui sera là également qui voit la
taxe embarquement voilà mais qui était
voilà je voulais savoir pourquoi
aussi elle et elle est allée passer chez
chez eric zemmour les voilà par lé passé
chez eric zemmour
les analystes mais c'est vrai qu'elle
aime d'eric zemmour j'ai l'impression
que maintenant même plus eric zemmour
tôt marine le pen voilà quelle et voilà
donc où je voudrais en savoir un petit
peu plus là-dessus et il y aura
vous n'avez toujours elisabeth morineau
notre ministre parlera bien entendu de
tout ce qu'il a dit sur les femmes et
sur
c'est sûr toutes les sorties qu'il a pu
faire là dessus et forcément elle sera
avec nous vous pouvez pas trouver mieux